le visage de la colère andré ici d'or
qui n'a 40 ans et il est russe il s'est
installé à kiev il ya plus de quinze ans
avec l'invasion russe il se sent
définitivement ukrainien
ici c'est ma maison comme pour le reste
des habitants de kiev je dois et je veux
aussi la protéger je suis déjà allé cinq
fois au bureau d'enrôlement militaire
mais il me renvoie parce que j'ai un
passeport russe
l'ukraine ex république soviétique qui a
connu deux révolutions pro démocratiques
depuis 2004 et est devenue une
destination d'exil pour les russes
sacha alexeyeva est arrivé à kiev il ya
quatre ans cette sociologue voulaient
fuir le régime de vladimir poutine
j'ai honte d'avoir dû coopérer avec des
entreprises russes à mon arrivée mais il
ya un an j'ai arrêté et j'ai commencé à
travailler uniquement avec des bureaux
aux ukrainiens pour beaucoup cette
guerre a ruiné des liens avec des
proches en russie qui soutiennent
l'invasion
175000 russes bénéficient d'un titre de
séjour en ukraine